il avait ouvert ses portes le 18 janvier
un peu plus d'un an après le
vaccinodromes de sky ferme ses portes
clap de fin vendredi 25 février une page
qui se tourne pour le personnel sur
place un mélange de nostalgie et de
satisfaction bilan de cette expérience
déjà je dirais humaine avant tout parce
que des rencontres avec toutes sortes de
professionnels de santé au niveau
ingénieur logistique
communication enfin vraiment tous les
corps de métier qu'on n'aurait peut-être
jamais eu l'occasion de rencontrer
ensuite la chance d'avoir pu participer
à cet élan national aujourd'hui les
besoins ne sont plus les mêmes la
période de vaccination massive est
terminée le vaccinodromes passe le
relais à la médecine de ville voilà
maintenant une médecine un peu moins
massives et plus de proximité
est suffisante nécessaire encore mais
suffisante pour être auprès des patients
et finir au mieux cette vaccination
mathieu le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines aura permis de
réaliser plus de 400000 injection une
prise en charge facile selon les
patients qui profitent des derniers
moments du centre pour se faire vacciner
mon médecin traitant m'a mis au courant
qui a parti d'où dernière vendredi dont
moi qui allait fermer l'eau ville de
rome mais ça c'est pas facile à trouver
aussi tu penses pourront s'en sevir le
médecin de ville a déjà beaucoup
d'occupations et ne serait ce que pour
quoi on a rendez-vous médical c'est très
compliqué pour avoir un rendez vous donc
je pense que oui la centre le centre de
vaccination c'est plus sympa quoi c'est
plus facile d'utilisation ovadia jour de
clôture du vaccinodromes vendredi 25
février il pourrait être réarmée en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie